on a lazy day taking the easy option
popping a ham and pineapple pizza in the
microwave whether it's fresh or frozen
pig sheep to go to a poultry meat
neutral to the cars of course
manufacturers estate where the animal
used was reared and slaughtered but how
helpful would that be escaped uber
Hopkins's am hung meeting father flash
scandal on Dinah here comes concessional
decide Jesus Parliament guns and oddish
fesco stared another argument against it
would raise production costs but by
making the buyer aware and keeping the
industry in check with a minimal
increment to be a bad trade-off this
could be really good for the food
industry helping to restore the trust in
their supply chain that has been so
badly damaged in recent years due to the
horsemeat scandal but for the head of a
Health Committee preventing a scandal
altogether should be the priority it is
a first step but we need to do more
steps for giving more security to the
consumer and to prevent for every John
Wednesday will decide where the process
meat gets put on the table for greater
regulation